francia hasta las puertas de una nueva
cuarentena nacional cuatro semanas con
nuevas restricciones para frenar el
avance de la pandemia que tendrán un
impacto en una economía ya golpeada solo
en pactos con respecto al impacto en la
economía lo estamos evaluando
actualmente por supuesto cuando se
cierran 150.000 negocios cuando hay todo
un sector del turismo que no puede
funcionar cuando se cierran las escuelas
esto por supuesto tendrá un impacto en
la actividad económica en 2021 estamos
en el proceso de poner esto en cifras y
daré más detalles en los próximos días
precisiones y quercus además con las
nuevas medidas el gobierno se gastará 11
mil millones de euros mensuales son
restricciones necesarias para tratar de
aligerar la carga en los hospitales esta
semana los pacientes en cuidados
intensivos superaron los cinco mil una
cifra que está por encima del repunte
vivido en otoño de 2020 durante el
segundo confinamiento
si corrimos a cómo se empieza a ser
difícil psicológicamente estamos muy
cansados atados al trabajo con poco
descanso en casa no podemos pasar tiempo
con los nuestros por la cuarentena
cuando une con yoko firmo es la tercera
ola de pandemia que atraviesa francia el
ministro de salud auguró que todavía
faltan días para superar el pico de
contagios y semanas para que la
situación mejore dijo que ustedes hacen
falta entre 7 y 10 días para que las
medidas sean eficaces es decir que
podríamos alcanzar el pico
epidemiológico el 7 o el 10 si tu camión
mientras tanto francia deposita las
esperanzas en la campaña de vacunación
que por el momento avanza más despacio
de lo previsto inicialmente